here this is why wildfires are so
terrifying in an instant it shifts grows
consuming everything and every one in
its wake
feel the heat oh my God
this was Nikki goyer's view from the
passenger seat at the very end you where
the right to the right that is where we
felt the most intense heat in the car
you could feel a little bit of warmth
driving through it but most of it it was
just the fear of all the red
the red the glow is all that lights up
the skies here in West Kelowna and
British Columbia where tens of thousands
of people have evacuated or been told to
with unknown numbers of homes and
buildings already destroyed we will
start counting the number of houses when
we stop fighting the fires that are
burning today
soon as we know we'll share the
information Jeff and Julie Hoffman
evacuated but they say their Community
is keeping them updated on what they
left behind remotely with doorbell
cameras we're on a Facebook group a
community Facebook group that just is
posting constantly uh here's how things
look right now out the front door it
just gives peace people some peace of
mind a reassuring glance at their past
and they hope their future after this
experience that they say has only
strengthened their love of this area we
were generously offered our friend's
house while they're out of town and
we've heard again just hundreds of
people offering their places offering
their acreages to store all their
vehicles and their
and their toys and their things
this has been a terrible Wildfire season
for many parts of Canada right now the
country is battling over 1 000 wildfires
many of those classified out of control
and headed toward new communities every
day
Patty colhane Al Jazeera
foreign